[Música]
é princípio pio
a princípio havia não sei não deixa
sentar com os russos
eu trago uma história e uma história
mitológica contada por ele está o fãs no
banquete de um curioso não é que eu
estou debate o estoque estava contente
soluços
na hora de falar devido aos excessos do
banco da véspera que teve que passar a
palavra o outro orador
enquanto isso a companhia do ataque dos
russos
eu estava ali reunidos para discutir o
amor e eu parece que já estou melhor e
que não tenha que passar a palavra outro
jogador e espero é princípio havia três
gênios da humanidade
o feminino
o masculino
o andrógeno eram três poderiam ser mais
a maioria das sociedades nativas
americanas considerava o feminino uma
sculli no e no total
atualmente a mac mini bugs que ele tem
no fundo de sua vez e nem do nézia neste
time existe mulher homem mulher tomou a
opção de viver como homem a homem que
tomou a opção de viver como mulher
já são quatro eo gênero completo a
incorporação do feminino e do masculino
um senhor chamado nico divino
responsável pela comunicação entre o
mundo dos vivos dos deuses e dos
antepassados
mas e se o fez um sexto e um sétimo bom
mas voltando aristófanes e um banquete
de platão pe
a princípio havia 13 anos na humanidade
o feminino masculino o andrógeno neste
sentido tudo cada ser humano tem a forma
de uma esfera com quatro braços quatro
pernas e duas caras ligados por um único
pescoço arredondado para estas duas
caras um único crânio com quatro orelhas
estas criaturas podia passear por onde
criou em posição ereta tal como nós hoje
mas quando necessitavam de correr travam
braços e pernas pro ar e graças aos oito
membros em que se apoiavam regulavam
glosas o homem era filho do sol é mulher
filha da terra e o android um filho da
lua seus pais tentaram vigor e força
terrível e rebeldia pois pensaram em
subir aos céus e atacar o divino
os deuses que deram logo castigá los mas
não sabiam como matá los a todos é o que
eles merecem
não há cinco anos adora ganhos presta
culto desta maneira discutiam entre 11 e
depois de muito discutir em e de muito
ponderar em já sei
cortamos cada um em dois ficam mais
fracos boa
dito isto começar a cortar escrituras em
dois como se fossem maçãs à medida que
escutavam voltava o rosto eo pescoço
pelo lado do corte de maneira a cada
acervo dessa data a cicatriz e lembrar
do que sofreu na origem depois puxavam e
apanhavam os pés de todos os lados para
a barriga e amarravam mas como quem
amarrou os cordões à bolsa em redor do
umbigo
ai ai ai ai olhou e e e uma vez
realizada esta divisão da natureza
primitiva cantado dizendo outra é
procurava o cheiro estendeu os braços no
desejo de se unirem mas morreu de forma
e preguiça
pois não queriam fazer nada neste estado
de separação quando montado morria a
outra procurava procurava procurava
procurava procurava procurava procurava
mas a humanidade extinguir se assim os
deus tiveram pena das criaturas e
decidem encontrar sua forma de
reprodução até então por deus na terra
tal como as plantas passam agora a
produzir pela união da mulher com o
homem
o facto é que desde então que eu morei
na atual seres humanos cada um de nós é
um estado de uma peça vista escutaram
maio como maçãs o peru e cada um vai
procurar outra metade da sua peça
assim todas as mulheres que provém da
divisão do android no primitivo irmãos
homens tal como os homens é nos mulher
quando eu vi olhos de marcha e boca de
amora silvestre tanto mel tanto sol
nessa tua mar deixa por phil sumarento e
agra
é este o quanto as mulheres aprovou
ainda a divisão de uma mulher primitiva
estas não prestam muita atenção aos
homens voltam-se anos para as mulheres e
é indispensável que essa mulher se a mãe
foi na certeza que era isto o meu doce
de uva e nós sobremesa o amor de morango
e caju
hum
por último todos os homens propaganda de
visão do homem primitivo
esses eram os homens pensam em casar com
uma mulher
não é porque caíram mas apenas
constrangidos pelo costume é também
muito importante que este homem se a mãe
tem um travo laranja e no beijo três
gomos do riso tanto mel tanto sol frutas
uma água fresca provar e pediu juízo e
riso quando os amantes descobrem precisa
aumentar diz que é sua admirável como
empolgados com a ternura e pelo amor em
kmt na sexta
rizzi dar meia volta à cabeça o álbum
vai encarar também ceder
quero ter o amor de água fresca
[Música]
o banquete de platão foi escrito por
volta do ano 300 e 80 anos do cristo e
esta breve história
apesar de algumas adaptações podem ser
encontradas na sobra na grécia clássica
o berço da civilização ocidental
os pensadores sentavam se à mesa do
banquete avança e discutiam sobre o que
entregava
felizmente que hoje é ver muitas outras
maneiras de conjugar e de namorar as
frutas e pensa que não precisa
simplificar mas o abacate com uma maçã
abacaxi maçã qual o problema
na verdade eu não sei se acredito em
cada juntado em almas gêmeas
mas sem dúvida que a pessoa porque
sentimos um magnetismo uma conexão
incrível mas terá mesmo a nossa
felicidade enquanto dessa cara pintada
fraca e merece toda essa
responsabilidade
então e ficamos aspecto princesas e
príncipes sem os quais não somos ninguém
eu penso que cultivar a felicidade é
realmente da responsabilidade de cada um
um corpo pode potenciar mas não é
salvação para todos os maus estava com
outros quem pode estar bem com outros
não estiver bem consigo a relação mais
certa que temos para toda a vida é
relação conosco
esta breve cena com as frutas que vão se
apresentar é o cheiro de uma peça de
teatro de uma criação minha estreado há
pouco tempo e eu tenho a sensação que
quando apresentou as pessoas questionam
acerca da identidade sexual
talvez isso tenha passado pela cabeça
tanto é que tenho um amigo que depois
desse estilo disso
graça moniz lésbica
eu acho incrível a necessidade que temos
que rotular as coisas diz cada lugar e
te catar o que não está equipado
causa-nos confusão organização mental
bom eu apenas sei que poderia apaixonar
por qualquer ser humano que me
encantasse independentemente do seu
gênero parece que vai mostrar muito para
além de categorias numa cultura rótulos
gavetas identidades constantemente tem
que ser sessões e adaptações porque já
não comporta uma diversidade de formas
de mar e pensa que essas identidades em
que nos encaixando engavetam de
hostilidade e possibilidades e não para
os que entrarem ou restringirem bombas
finalizando em uma tentativa de
responder à questão para o homem ao mote
este encontro
eu penso que seria positivo continuamos
a caminhar para uma sociedade aberta
onde cada um é cada um pode ser que o
que é onde temos o direito a sermos como
somos mesmo sendo uma minoria desafio
então é continuarmos a caminhar para um
mundo onde podemos cultivar a nossa
originalidade e forma única de ser
obrigado
[Aplausos]